tomorrow night President Trump is
formally launching his re-election
campaign in Orlando Florida and as I
said the crowd is already lining up 40
hours early but the usual suspects in
the media were falling all over
themselves to preemptively rain on the
rally and they think that president
Trump's ABC News interview with George
Stephanopoulos gave them their opening
the president states has abdicated his
oath of office he did it just the other
day on George Stephanopoulos to this
interview he's not protecting the
national security interest of the United
States he's not committed to protecting
or election integrity and security yes
he is and as we explained last weekend
the angle that argument is absurd now in
fact in many critical areas the Trump
administration has taken a tougher
stance against Russia than the Obama
administration has done we've documented
that show after show but none of that
matters when the reporter asking the
questions has an agenda
even if he's amiable in the process the
agenda namely to resuscitate and revisit
the Mullah report and even by the way
when the president expresses minor
annoyance not related to rush hour
Muller they try to make him out to be
the bad guy
some point out they get it because it's
a fantastic financial statement it's a
fantastic financial statement and let's
do that over he's coughing in the middle
of my answer yeah okay I don't like that
you know your chief of staff you get a
coffee please
you just can't just to change the shine
sorry okay you want to do that a little
differently then yeah we just changed
the angle yep thank you so at some point
so at some point I look forward to
frankly I want I'd like to have people
see my financial statement now everyone
who does TV knows they're honest but
that was lousy form for Stephanopoulos
not to stop the cameras from rolling
into air that entire exchange but hey
anything to advance the Trump's mean
narrative the last part there is so
telling where he kind of does the yeah
as though he has been wronged in some
meaningful way by his chief of staff
coughing or maybe it was all a plot one
theory I read it I didn't even think
about it from this perspective but given
the subject in the sensitivity
surrounding his tax returns somebody
pointed out that maybe it was Mick
Mulvaney trying to save the president
and not trying to create a soundbite
that could be used later on for ABC
coughed gate more goofiness how many
times have I said that to Raymon by the
way stop coughing I mean we were just
howling when this happened no it's all
get serious here though tomorrow in
Orlando the president has a chance to
just relaunch this campaign and just hit
every note and I think part of it it's
just kind of shrugging off the
inclination to relitigate every past
issue insult weed investigation and the
best way to frame all of this is look at
what we've been able to accomplish even
with two years of the Russia hoax
you've got the stock market flirting
with record highs when you have this
near record low unemployment we have GDP
growth continuing at better than
expected rates under Obama Biden 200,000
manufacturing jobs were lost and under
President Trump in just three years
450,000 manufacturing jobs have been
added unemployment is the lowest that's
been here in the United States since
1969 job growth is strong hourly wages
are up that should just be the playlist
for Trump 2020 if any other president
we're doing the things Trump is doing
for this economy for jobs for workers
taking on China most in the media would
be throwing rose petals in a parade
every time he showed up I mean who else
has worked so diligently despite
congressional inaction to lower
prescription drug prices we're promoting
price transparency to force competition
and drive down cost and that's what's
happening and that's one of the reasons
we're getting the drug prices stopping
from those tremendous increases that
have taken effect for so many years for
so many decades they've been going only
in one direction
up who else has cut regulations like
this president has to unburden American
businesses who else is recognized and
responded to the crisis at the border
like Trump using the threat of
terrorists and diplomatic pressure drops
even gotten Mexico to step up finally on
their immigration enforcement president
Trump's new immigration deal with Mexico
starting to show an impact some 6,000
Mexican soldiers now deployed here along
the country's southern border with
Guatemala stopping some coming in on
rafts as well as some larger caravans
including a group of trucks carrying
some 800 migrants stopped near the Texas
border over the weekend well but for
Trump they all would have surely made it
to the US border and who else has stood
up to the Chinese on the world stage to
end the ongoing Beijing orchestrated
ripoff of American industries and
intellectual property only Trump and I
haven't even talked about criminal
justice reform tax reform renegotiating
NAFTA to benefit American workers
judicial appointments and the only
response from Democrats who are running
for president is Russia identity
politics demonizing wealth creators and
of course the go-to will give you free
stuff every American regardless of his
or her income is entitled to the right
to a decent job that pays a living wage
technical school two-year college for
your public college all be free and
tuition free for all of our kids I think
that anyone who is in a situation where
they're in need of health care
regardless of whether they're documented
or undocumented we have an obligation to
see to their character well they leave
out the part where you're going to pay
through the nose for all of this while
the government makes more decisions for
you your family and your business that
means less freedom well Trump needs to
remind America that if they send Bernie
or Elizabeth or even Uncle Joe to the
White House the Democrat socialists will
eventually run out of other people's
money and what happens then the
country's economy will crumble into an
abyss of mediocrity oh god oh god please
no no no no that's how I feel and on a
serious note the Trump reelection
message should be simple do you want to
keep the good times going and make
America even stronger are you better off
than you were in January 2017 some of
you may not like some of trumps tweets
but you're gonna hate what Democrats
will do to the prosperity that his
policies have created and that's the
angle